[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so next person we have is Patricia she
is the creator of gay fi where you can
make your software gay and your
debugging more colorful okay and even
cooler than that she can do the splits
when I make a dude on stage today but
that's awesome so me later
ask her later so please give a warm
welcome for Patricia thanks everyone
so thanks for coming to my talk thanks
for making it through end of the day you
know it's been busy conference day so my
talk a tale of two bundles a lesson in
mentorship so before I dive in Who am I
I'm Patricia I'm a back-end software
engineer at Tkaczyk in Washington DC and
you can follow me and tweet at me at
queer Pat so in this talk I'm gonna be
speaking about my journey of breaking
into tech as a bootcamp grad to become a
back-end software engineer as a queer
Latinas woman with a degree in the
humanities in my talk today I'll be
highlighting the vital differences
between a negative mentor who actually
blocks underrepresented folks from
breaking into tech further perpetuating
the leaders hierarchy omnipresent
throughout the tech companies versus an
invaluable mentor who nurtures and
sponsors their mentees by leveraging any
privilege that they have to open career
opportunities for their mentees then I
will further examine how exactly to
become an effective mentor and sponsor
for underrepresented folks in tech and
this is going to be through my own
personal ends and lived experiences
so a little bit of background about me
so years ago I had a dead-end job as a
textbook copy editor at a major
educational publisher fed up with the
lack of opportunities I would go home
after work and teach myself Python some
JavaScript I really wanted to try and
incorporate programming into my job at
my job at the textbook company we had
online versions of our textbooks and
they were you can interact with them
through a CMS and I you know taught
myself HTML and CSS to edit our
textbooks so at the textbook company I
got really fed up I really wanted to
pursue programming more seriously so I
moved cross-country to attend a Python
coding boot camp in San Francisco when I
lived in San Francisco for the two years
after attending boot camp I grew a lot
technically I pushed myself by
constantly coding and building side
projects learning new programming
concepts as much as I could
learning so many new skills as quickly
as I did resulted in a lot of
metaphorical growing pains learning is
hard learning takes energy and effort
continuously stretching your mind is
draining and applying for software
engineer jobs is very time consuming and
energy draining so my non-traditional
path into tech was very challenging
sometimes I was so frustrated and
disillusioned with the tech industry and
the Game of Thrones battle that is
technical interviewing I wanted to give
up a lot it really felt that all of my
efforts until learning becoming more
technical and finishing lengthy
technical challenges were all in vain I
felt like I certainly had to prove
myself over and
over again in these tech interviews and
job searching becomes even more
frustrating when your mentors in a way
Gaslight you from progressing
career-wise and discourage you from
applying to technical positions so for
more context my boot camp actually
assigned its students mentors from the
software engineering community so not
only did these boot camp
mentors tell me I was not ready to start
interviewing which is that's one piece
but then they never guided me on what
technical topics I should study to best
prepare for technical interviewing these
boot camp mentors made what I think is
an unfair judgment call blocking me from
network opportunities to further my
career these pre assigned mentors from
my boot camp did in fact mentor me in
the sense that they tutored me they
tutored me with computer science
concepts but they failed to sponsor me
they failed to architect a long-term
plan with me and what exactly I wanted
to accomplish in my programming career
in my opinion mentorship should not just
consists of only tutoring mentees but
also opening out potential job
opportunities as well as architecting a
plan on how to accomplish the mentees
long-term goals so during this point of
my journey it definitely felt like these
bootcamp mentors were in a way
weaponizing my junior 'no Segen Smee I
felt tokenized so that white software
engineer men got Ally cookies from
mentoring me so that they could feel
good about themselves it's not a great
feeling to be surrounded by these pseudo
Ally allies who want to feel woke it was
very discouraging because I felt like my
boot camp mentors did not have faith in
me
so with the long job hunt a little bit
of context for my very long job hunt in
breaking into tech so after finishing my
boot camp I had managed to cobble
together about a year's worth of
technical experience via a contract job
an open-source fellowship I was awarded
at github as well as an internship at a
tech health start-up so my internship at
the tech health startup was supposedly
for a position that was contract to hire
contractor hired positions were very
common amongst boot camp graduates so
unfortunately after a round of layoffs
neither myself nor any of my fellow
bootcamp grad software engineer interns
received full-time offers so and thus
began my very long nine months a job
hunt so during this job hunt I
experienced many lows external factors
made the job hunt particularly difficult
at one point I had unstable housing in
San Francisco all the while trying to
not resort moving back in with my
homophobic parents who I was not out to
at the time and I really feared a
negative reaction from them if they ever
found out I was queer so I was balancing
adulting which is really hard while also
trying to survive these super long
technical interviewing processes many
times honestly I felt like I was being
hazed by the tech industry I felt like I
was a so many like trivia like
algorithms and data structure questions
that were completely and extremely far
removed from the day-to-day job of a
software engineer I had so many awkward
pair programming
or men would just silently watch me code
judging me for solving their problem in
a very unique way that they had never
seen before so oops
excuse me so my lowest point in my
nine-month technical interviewing
journey was actually towards the end of
my search so by this point of my job
search I had failed so many times in
past technical interviews I was actually
like fairly decent at making it past
technical homework challenges as well as
technical phone screens and had a decent
rate at making it to final on-site
interviews so my absolute rock bottom
low point was during a week-long paid
final on-site interview at a software
engineering consulting firm essentially
it was like a short-term freelancing
opportunity so this was what was going
through my mind I almost didn't even
accept the week-long interview requests
because this particular consultancy at
the time was ten men there was no women
you know the fact that their interview
process included a week of vetting their
applicants made it obvious to me that
most of their applicants weren't parents
or caregivers or you know any developers
with time-consuming responsibilities
outside of the office and then it also
let me know that the applicants applying
to this consultancy they must have not
had full-time jobs as taking a week off
of work for most people
is untenable especially taking a week
off of like childcare or elder care
responsibilities it's just unreachable
so unfortunately
regardless of these red flags I ended up
doing a week of freelancing with them
because I needed the money I had to pay
my bills and my funds were scarce since
this was such a long job search so it
was obvious to me from like the first
hour of freelancing with this
consultancy that was a very bad but this
consultancy was dogmatic about using
them as a text editor of choice to
contrast I love using Adam as my text
editor so during my week of freelancing
I had to pair a program with each
consultant and it became extremely
difficult to pair since every consultant
have their own super customized than
bindings so ended up unfortunately
happening was that every consultant was
dravite getting so like both driving as
well as navigating in pair programming
speak so it's very difficult to
collaborate with them as they were
hogging the keyboard you know just it
just seemed like they just didn't want
to collaborate with me or share context
with me it was just very difficult I
even brought up the fact to them that
exclusively using them was a major
obstacle for me since when trying to
collaborate I'm obviously much slower at
collaborating than the fellow
consultants there and unfortunately I
was met with a lot of pushback and quite
frankly text-editor elitism so it was
really unfortunate so unfortunately this
week and did very poorly
I believe it ended in medical flames
because towards the end of the last day
the engineers they took me out to lunch
I was kind of like a goodbye lunch and
so unfortunately one of the white
software engineers
like extremely like races anti-black
joke to the only black software engineer
in the consultancy and so i would and he
made this joke in front of me you know
like my jaw dropped
i couldn't believe what he had said i
was speechless
unfortunately didn't speak up I didn't
say anything I wish I did I was just I
was just shocked I didn't know what to
say
so that was by far the lowest point of
my job search I was seriously
considering just quitting tech as an
industry altogether you know I felt
super other during the end of that
freelancing gig you know I feel like I
didn't belong and you know if one of
these like software engineers at this
consultancy obviously treated the black
software engineer poorly like how would
they cheat me like they wouldn't treat
me well if I had worked there so
thankfully things started to look up in
my programming journey so in spite of
all of this hazing and all these
prejudice prejudice is embedded and
technical interviewing I'm here I've
successfully broken into tech as a
full-time back-end software engineer
with the guidance of mentors and support
from friends I persisted I survived a
lot of adversity and I was driven to
find a company to accept me for my
authentic self in my opinion it's my
strong belief that I did not break into
tech by relentlessly improving my
programming skills because I personally
knew many people who had landed
full-time jobs who were definitely less
technical than I were I was I believe
that the rosy narrative that coding boot
camps market to their students that if
they just diligently study computers
concepts and build side projects to
extend their programming skills that
their hard work will pay off in an
attractive software engineering job I
believe this is like an incomplete false
narrative in my opinion I was able to
successfully break into the gatekeeping
that is technical interviewing was
because I made strong connections in the
career not man community I have this
queer community to thank for opening up
wonderful career opportunities these
more experienced queer not men Engineers
lent me some of their privilege by
mentoring me and sponsoring me mentoring
especially for underrepresented folks in
tech not only should include helping
mentees solidify technical concepts but
also open doors for them in networking
and new employment opportunities so an
important facet of being a great mentor
is not just teaching mentees about
technical concepts but opening up
opportunities and also architecting a
future plan of what goals a mentee wants
to accomplish over time so this really
contrasts with my negative experience
with my pre-assigned mentors from my
coding boot camp so I was sponsored by
the queer community they leveraged their
own personal networks to introduce me to
recruiters and hiring managers they used
their name to vouch on my behalf would
tell potential employers that I'm an
excellent communicator that I learned
fast and I'm a good team player
thankfully this enabled me to land my
first full-time software engineer job so
this all happened because I was very
lucky that I was thankfully paired up
with my wonderful mentor cut my tongue
CLI engineer and pee
who is a major positive force in my
journey in tech so I first talked to Kat
via this inclusive slack community
called we all J yes we all jus is a
unique in the sense that it's an
experiment to see if a very diverse
group of Internet strangers interested
in JavaScript could get along and not
devolve into you know antagonist ik
argumentative environment so about two
years ago and we all join us there was a
call for mentorship where
underrepresented folks were looking to
break into tech could be paired with a
more senior experienced mentor so I was
very lucky cat chose me as mentee
I chose Kat as a mentor and it just
happened to be that we are both queer
and quad Rican I'm very lucky to have a
wise mentor that is also queer and
Puerto Rican like myself as there aren't
many queer Puerto Rican and non mint
engineers in tuk all right excuse me I
got kind of out of out of sync with my
slides
okay
all right cool so an important pillar of
mentorship is technical guidance so can
I would go over technical concepts such
as how does the internet work and what
is restfulness I would also ask Kat
questions on how to go about solving
coding challenges like big picture wise
like what data structure should I use
what tools do I use do I build a rails
app do I build a gem many times I would
actually reach for rails new building a
new rails app that's my first instinct
since that was what I was most familiar
with but cat would suggest many times
for these back-end technical challenges
that an entire app is overkill you know
sometimes the building a gem or even a
script would suffice and you know that
would leave me more time for focusing on
like optimizations Reba robust testing
and like fleshing out any algorithms
that I wrote so even more importantly
cat would teach me foe paws to avoid for
example as someone who is self-taught
sometimes I will already be familiar
with a technical concept but I won't
know the official term that it's called
or other times I'll have like read a
particular buzz word but I'm not sure
how to pronounce it since I've never
said it out loud before so an example of
this word was idempotent I had a lot of
trouble you know saying this word out
loud and so cat knows I love emojis and
I'm very visual learner and so they like
came up with this like I den potent sand
emojis the soup is kind of like fun so
you know
it was it really helped me like remember
how to say this technical term so I was
really thankful for that another
important part of being a great mentor
is architecting with your mentee a plan
a plan of what they want to accomplish
in the future so this is true even when
you're meant to you is not even exactly
sure of what they want their future to
look like so in the beginning of mine
and cats mentor mentee relationship
I wasn't even completely sure that I
wanted to pursue back-end development
you know I had I was still considering
pursuing front-end development I had
done a lot of like exploration on my own
was leaning towards back in but honestly
I wasn't even sure so in order for me to
make a well-informed decision Kat told
me about specific hardships that I would
have to navigate as a not man when
pursuing front end versus back end
development so Kat told me that the
relationship non men have with front-end
development is complicated they
explained to me how the tech industry
sometimes devalues front-end work
especially HTML and CSS work and that
many times this work is strongly
associated with non men there's this
biased idea that women are good at
making things look pretty and that
back-end development is too hard so that
we're most likely to be siloed into
front-end I obviously think front-end
development is very complex but that's
that's the insight Kat told me industry
wise that I should just be aware and so
this contrasted with the advice that I
got for back-end development that
there's much fewer non men software
engineers in the backend and that I
should be prepared at future jobs to be
the only person who looks the way that I
do
so another point that's really important
to be a really effective mentor is that
mentors should help mentees design
personalized strategies on how to
approach the job search so Kath worked
with me so we could best navigate the
technical interviewing landscape to best
suit my specific needs so in my case I
was super overwhelmed by all of the
responses I was getting from cold
applying to a high number of tech
companies each week it was impossible
for me to complete all of the number of
technical challenges and interview
requests that I was getting from them so
Kath helped me pivot to a new strategy
where I only applied to companies where
I could get a referral from untrusted
underrepresented person in tech I've met
in real life from Twitter or we all
jeaious or again an ally from that is
trusted from any of those communities so
this shift in job searching was also in
hopes to try and filter out a lot of
horrible technical interviewing
experiences I was already accustomed to
so I argue that the most important facet
of mentorship is sponsorship effective
mentorship cannot happen without
sponsorship mentors should use their
privilege and network to open
communities for their mentees so I was
very lucky and Kat leveraged their
connections within the package manager
community and introduced me to on Jay
Arco he is the CTO of Ruby together
which is a nonprofit that funds
development work for the Ruby ecosystem
specifically for rubygems and bundler so
Andre is lead developer for bundler
which is the dependency manager gem for
the Ruby ecosystem so bundler is kind of
like the Ruby NPM so thankfully NPM and
bundler are good friends because of this
friendship this friendship opened doors
for my career so my experience is that
really together were overwhelmingly
positive
I was hired as a software engineer for
Ruby together to maintain Butler here
iTriage open github issues I answered
users questions I improved documentation
I translated documentation I added tests
and then I also submitted PRS for bugs
so Andre was an invaluable mentor
because he would clearly break down
challenging bundler concepts so I could
understand them something else that was
like super interesting and helpful was a
and J also told me about Ruby history
before I even started Ruby which is
super valuable just for a context so at
Ruby together
I really dive deep into Ruby I learned
methods and numerable x' that i never
would have even have touched or seen if
I'd only ever written
so another really cool thing that I
learned at Ruby together was I learned
how to build and release gems to Ruby
gems so I built a jam called gay of hi
so gay of Faiza gem that prepends
colorful queer emojis to your exceptions
[Music]
excuse me technical difficulties okay so
basically whenever you mess up in the
rails console for GFI you'll get like
really cute emojis to hopefully bring up
your day
so my work for bundler was very
impressive to perspective employers you
know my full-time job search even after
working a few short months at Ruby
together was already much more fruitful
I've no doubt in my mind that my
contributions to bundler helped me land
my current back-end software engineering
position I found out that employers
really value experience in the package
manager space and look highly upon
building and releasing gems so I would
like to show you how KFI works so
basically this is a rails out you go to
your gem file you put jfi in it go back
to your terminal you bundle install
which is like NPM install it's all
installed and then you can open up the
rails console play around and then yeah
when you mess up you'll get awesome
emojis so hopefully you'll make your dip
agai debugging a little little happier a
little better so yeah some rainbows some
like kiss and like lipstick emojis
Sparkle emojis so yeah that was really
fun to build
so in spite of adversity the biases of
interviewers the super time-consuming
coding Giles and the feelings of being
other dand having to prove myself over
and over again in spite of all of that I
am here so my career in tech as a
back-end software engineer has taken off
now as I gained more and more privilege
in tech and the more senior I become
I really hope to both mentor and sponsor
underrepresented folks like myself
trying to break into tech I want to
bring underrepresented folks up with me
as I rise I want to pay it forward so
that other underrepresented folks become
a part of tech so thank you very much
for coming to my talk if your company
uses Ruby or you're passionate about
helping fund upper represented folks to
get paid for open-source work
Ruby together always welcomes company
and individual donations and also my
company KITT Chuck is currently hiring
for two back in software engineer
positions so feel free to reach out to
me via Twitter thank you so much
[Applause]